well i love the vision and one of the
reasons why
um i love it is that it just values
people's time
at a more appropriate rate one of the
reasons why like i'm
pro-universal basic income relative to
other measures is that it values some of
the time that right now doesn't
get considered as uh employment and
right
um you know like for example you know my
wife is at home with our boys and you
know like uh right that
doesn't count zero in gdp calculation
yeah zero
but but there is but the the same
principle applies where
if you're elevating people's wages
you're just valuing people's time more
like 100 percent on pro ubi is like you
should just value people's time
like intrinsically and right like so but
the principle
um is is very similar it's one reason
why when you talk about
um you know elevating these things like
i i just imagine more human dignity
which there
there is um immediately so so you
surprise yourself and win
um and then you're like oh my gosh like
we're getting this done in seattle and
then
that happens 90 days that's right and
then yeah and then
you know and seiu drove it super hard
and super successfully around the
country
um yeah that's right mary kay henry did
an
extraordinary job in leadership there um
cj grimes who ran the national fight for
15
was amazing and a bunch of other people
who you know i could mention but
then the question to your point is
andrew what's next
right because the minimum wage is like
it's a start but there's a thousand
things that you can do
and i will tell you in my opinion what
the second most important thing is
that we have been fighting since 2014 i
think
is the overtime threshold speaking of
time
so the overtime threshold is the
threshold below which
if you if you work for more than 40
hours a week they have to pay you time
and a half
and in the day like when we used to have
a thriving middle class
40 years ago that threshold covered
not just 100 of hourly workers
but it also covered 62
of salaried workers which means that
effectively
it covered almost everybody except the
big bosses
okay and what happened over 45 years of
neoliberalism
is that that so a people like me
turned uh hourly workers
into salaried workers and pitched them
fake titles like assistant manager or
director of you're on your way filing
yes
and you get a business card and
then that standard fell um
to to and it just got updated but
as of last year if you earned 23
600 a year or less
you've got overtime but that means if
you earn 23 700
federally and i call you assistant
manager i can make you work 70 hours a
week
and not pay you one more dollar than i
was keynes projected
that we'd have like a 15 hour work week
by now because we're so productive
um and then he got the productivity
number right but our work week has just
gotten longer and longer because of some
of the things they're describing because
i was like oh you're there and like work
is
work just kind of expands yes it does
it does and because people like
me employing other people had this
enormous incentive
to turn three 40-hour a week jobs
into two 60-hour week jobs right
as if i don't have any limit on how hard
i can press people to work
then what i want to do is is
get two people to work as much as three
used to and
pocket the difference right
imagine how profitable that is
imagine how profitable that is
to have a thousand people working 40
hours a week
and then on presto magico now you have
650 people working 60 hours a week
for the same price i remember one of the
things that
that expanded the work week and this is
going to date me a little bit but
whatever
um it was blackberries like as soon as
you had a blackberry then like then
people could get you any time and then
obviously that morphed into smartphones
and people can get
people any time and now no for sure week
goes on forever
but one of the reasons the work week
goes on forever
is that all those people with
blackberries were not
protected by this labor standard right
because in the day you couldn't get
people to work at home they'd be like
well now you have to pay me overtime
so is the plan to have the overtime
threshold uh
applied to uh salaried workers as well
as wage workers well
it is presently applied to salaried
workers
at 32 000 a year which applaud which
effectively is
almost no salaried workers um but again
using this theory of local first
change in washington state last year we
pushed
through uh the nation's highest uh
overtime
threshold i believe i believe it is tell
us more tell us
more and at full implementation it will
be at about eighty three thousand
dollars
so what we are presently doing is
is putting pressure on the department of
labor and the biden administration
to in either enact a law or change the
labor standard
so that if you earn 83
000 a year or less you are automatically
entitled to overtime pay it time and a
half if you work
more than 40 hours a week this would be
transformative and i will say it would
be
a job creator in many many contexts
because someone would look up and say
wait a minute
um i'm going to have to pay my workers
overtime because right now they're
working
55 hours a week and that's time and a
half so how about i go employ
like another set of people to try and
keep everyone at 40.
that's right and so one of the secrets
to understanding
why wages have not risen for a really
long time
is that if you can 40 million
times across the economy turn three jobs
into two
well you've taken 15 million jobs out of
the economy plus or minus or 12 million
jobs or whatever it is
right and this is why structural
unemployment is so high
is because companies can get workers to
work more hours
without being forced to hire more people
and so everybody's just on this
treadmill and we're talking to
um the folks who work for marty walsh in
in the
labor department and um but we're also
circulating the idea of actually passing
this legislatively
um between you and me if i was biden
i would want to try to pass this
legislatively because
just politically and economically there
is no policy that is available to
democrats
that more directly benefits
middle-class people do you know what i
mean like the minimum wage is
fantastic this would be a yeah no this
would be a big deal for a lot of people
it would be a huge transformative deal
for tens of millions of americans
many of whom voted for donald trump in
the last election
right okay nick so yeah so what is the
catchy name
for uh for this measure
well it's overtime and i guess what
you're saying to me is
that's a really crappy not very catchy
name
so i know i i am suggesting that nick
because
which i'm admitting because right now
i'm like
let's champion overtime before people
are like all right
like what does that mean though i
understand how
incredibly uh transformative it would be
positively
wait wait wait i've got i've got i've
got i've got i got it okay
all right fight for 40 fight for
40. that's a good you know what that's
pretty goddamn good
that's not bad right because fight for
15 was very very
successful and alliterative and like you
hear it so if you say fight for 40.
a star is born i think it's pretty good
it's pretty good right because you're
here and you're like
like fight for 40 you're like 40 bucks
an hour it's like no 40 hours a week
and then you're like oh [ __ ] 40 hours a
week um and then it's like yeah and if
you're working for more than that then
you should get paid overtime and
everyone will be like hell yeah
fight for 40 nick i think that is
absolutely terrific
i i well more to come
on all the little buttons we're going to
have a little asterisk and say
bye andre yang no no no no no credit
necessary just freaking um as long as it
happens
you know like i'm i'm i'll be very very
glad
and and you know one of the most
encouraging things going is the biden
administrations
and you know i think the democratic
party's acknowledgment
generally that this is a
time for bold action yeah that's that's
been what my conversations with them
have also
indicated like they need to deliver the
goods
they have a window of time where that
like government has to demonstrate that
it can actually
improve [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah and so
you know the time is ripe for i think a
much more constructive dialogue about
this particular thing let the fight for
40 commence
if that becomes a thing i'm going to be
so proud nick i'm not going to lie
it's a really good idea uh i i i'm
being serious uh as soon as i hang up
i'm going to run that by some people i
think it's incredibly clever
[Music]
you